- Alright, I'm gonna do a big ol' twirl.
(guys yelling woah)
(rock music)
My name is Tak and I'm
a designer for Aria.
I like it.
And I brought some beautiful
gowns with me today
and I'm gonna turn these
guys into beautiful brides.
- Hi, Tak.
- Hi everyone.
- [Tak] So, I just need
to know a little bit
about your personalities.
- Well, I'm married, so my wife
has been through this before,
but I wasn't there.
- I really like fashion.
- Like a mini horse or a
teacup pig as my ring bearer.
- And I wanna look really hot.
- I want my wedding to be very fun.
- I like things that are couture.
- I want it to be a little quirky.
- Vin Diesel's probably officiating.
I don't know if he's free.
- I'm a pretty classic guy.
I like to wear polo shirts.
- When I think of Ned, I think of,
that ass doe.
- That ass.
- He's a business in the front type guy
who needs a party in the back.
- That is cute as (beep).
- This is my day. I want all eyes on me.
- Keith is one of the most exquisite,
beautiful creatures I know.
- I think Keith should
have something funky.
- I wanna look like Naomi Campbell.
- Eugene's gonna look
prettier than any of us.
Let's just get it over with.
- I think I have just
the dress for you, Ned.
- Alright.
- [Tak] You ready to try it on?
- Yeah, of course.
- You ready for it?
- Yes.
- You'd get a lot of attention
in this big ball gown.
- Hell yeah!
- Very revealing.
- Look at that bosom.
- That's a high fashion pose.
- Looks like you're a hunchback.
- Your lower half is so hairy!
- Oh, it's so silky.
- What is this?
- It is a petticoat.
- I'm gonna be so fluffy.
- That just slid on like a glove.
- Oh, it is tight in the back.
- I would have to get this dress altered.
- As soon as you start wearing that,
seeing your nipples becomes weird.
- Literally spaghetti on my shoulders.
- Ned, you didn't tell
us you were pregnant.
- Michelle is 16.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Oh, you get to dive into it.
- I feel like Big Bird, but hot.
- Da da da da, da da da da.
- What is this made out of?
- [Tak] Chicken feathers.
- Chicken feathers?
- Uh oh, boobs don't fill it out.
- This is a mermaid cut.
- You should never cut a mermaid.
- I feel like a princess,
a hairy Jewish princess.
(guys yelling ohhh!)
- I can't move, I'm stuck.
- Oh my God, those clamps!
- I feel like there's
something missing though.
- I have just the thing to
complete your look for you.
- Oh my God, it's like a cape.
- I'm getting married.
- Boys, you ready?
- You gotta look to us.
- Wow.
- Damn it. He looks great.
- He looks pretty decent.
- Yeah.
- Ahh!
- Aww.
- You look so weird!
- It's like in the Walgreens,
they always have that
thing around Halloween
that's like (creepy sound).
- Was that weird for you, Ned?
- I think Keith looks
more handsome than ever.
- Do you, Eugene, take
Keith to be your bride?
- Go get it, bro.
- In for the kiss.
- Not the dress, not the
dress, not the dress!
(laughter)
- Got him. Got him.
- I think it's really nice to find a dress
that matches your personality.
- [Voiceover] I feel so pretty in it.
- [Voiceover] It's a special day
and you wanna find something
that you feel special in.
- Also, I just think it's fun
to hang out with your friends
and sort of like, try on
some clothes together.
- This veil is digging into my head,
but just like, the way
that it makes me feel,
and all of the emotions that
the wedding day implies,
I just feel so perfect and beautiful
and I know that all of
the brides out there
who are getting married,
you're going to be so
perfect and beautiful
and I can't wait for you to get married.
- [Voiceover] You should
lose five pounds though.
- Shut the (beep) up, Eugene!
I will literally cut you!
- I'm just saying, it would
make you look perfect.
- God damn it!
- Near perfect, but like five pounds.
- No, no.
- You would look like, perfect.
- It was a nice moment and you ruined it.
- I'd be a very realistic bridesmaid.
- You look drunk.